on va parler un petit peu de sport Zumba
badminton athlétisme ou encore Street
workout de nombreuses activités
sportives sont disponibles en libre
accès dans la commune d'Élancourt
jusqu'au mois de juin c'est dans le
cadre du Printemps du sport pour en
parler avec nous Thierry Michel le
premier adjoint Homère à Élancourt alors
en début d'émission vous nous parlez un
petit peu des objectifs de du Printemps
du sport notamment encouragé l'activité
physique mais aussi faire découvrir aux
habitants les associations sportives et
les infrastructures sportives oui tout à
fait aujourd'hui sport il est pratiqué
de trois manières en matière scolaire on
voit effectivement qu'on a
accompagnement et nous mettons à
disposition les équipements que détient
la commune et on fait même des
accompagnements avec le savoir nager le
savoir rouler en acheter des vélos et
les enfants après narouler dans l'école
donc ça c'est une première manière de
faire du sport il y a la manière par le
tissu associatif on connaît tous on
vient s'inscrire dans une association
sur un sport qu'on a envie de faire on
vient chercher aussi de la compétition
et puis de plus en plus se développe le
sport loisirs le sport plaisir qui s'est
peut-être encore plus développé avec la
crise sanitaire donc aujourd'hui on a
effectivement la population qui dit je
veux faire du sport mais le tissu
associatif ne peut pas toujours répondre
à mes attentes notamment en matière
d'horaire donc c'est mieux que je puisse
faire deux activités et c'est ça qu'on a
voulu faire effectivement avec le
printemps du sport c'est de montrer tous
les équipements de faire aussi découvrir
nos associations parce qu'elles sont pas
toujours connues et de venir tester les
sports c'est ce qu'on fait dans le cadre
de l'association de la démo des
associations qui est un temps fort ou
beaucoup d'associations présentent leurs
activités alors justement quelles seront
les sports qui seront à tester ou à
découvrir l'espoir collectif l'histoire
individuel ça passe par tout ce qui
tourne autour des arts martiaux c'est le
rugby le football le foot américain le
volley-ball le basketball enfin bon j'en
oublie certainement mais j'espère que
les présidents de club m'en voudront pas
et il y aura aussi une zone de street
workout est-ce que vous pouvez nous
expliquer ce que c'est oui alors ça
c'est des nouveautés c'est de la
pratique du sport sport dans son
quartier aujourd'hui toujours dans ce
cas du sport un peu en matière libres on
a développé deux structures une dans le
quartier de la clef Saint-Pierre et une
qui est en cours de construction dans le
quartier des Petits Prés c'est
effectivement je fais du sport je fais
mon footing mais je veux aller sur des
équipements disponibles voilà on a une
aire qui est disponible avec même
capacité par des écrans de venir
chercher du programme et du contenu pour
quels exercices je vais faire
des contraintes horaires il y a la
contrainte financière pour la pratique
du sport c'est un moyen aussi de rendre
le sport plus accessible bien sûr parce
qu'aujourd'hui on est dans un contexte
qui est pas évident pour un certain
nombre de personnes c'est une manière de
dire venez faire du sport venez faire
surtout d'activité physique je crois que
le on baisse souvent le mot sport en
premier c'est l'activité physique il
faut rechercher c'est pour certains
c'est de la marche à travers des bords
de de bassin que nous avons sur la ville
où on aménage les chemins et c'est de
pouvoir et on le voit avec la population
qu'on rencontre qui nous demande
aujourd'hui on sent qu'il y a un échange
de plus en plus fort avec la population
qui me dit bah voilà dans mon quartier
il y a pas ça le regarda qui vont vous
demander du baskata 3 après bon on peut
pas tout installer non plus on essaie de
donner effectivement dans chaque
quartier la possibilité de venir
s'exprimer et donc tout est un accès
libre est-ce que il y aura quand même
des professionnels pour encadrer les
habitants effectivement on encadre les
habitants avec soit le personnel de la
commune nous avons dans des éducateurs
sportifs dans notre commune et on a tout
le bénévol du tissu associatif qui
viennent présenter en silence sport
est-ce que c'est un moyen aussi pour la
commune de créer plus de sociabilité ça
va faire se rencontrer les gens c'est un
bon moyen de faire des rencontres
associatif on est le meilleur exemple
c'est le Christ sanitaire bon qui s'est
achevé enfin parlons pas trop rapidement
à montrer toutes les faiblesses et
physiquement de d'organisation et on en
a tous s'exprimer ce besoin d'être
dehors et encore une fois le tissu
associatif répond en grande majeure
partie mais j'ai aujourd'hui on trouve
chez des personnes une autre volonté de
faire du sport tardivement on voit des
gens qui courent très très tôt le matin
on va essayer effectivement de pouvoir
les accompagner et alors en tant que 1er
ma adjoint à Élancourt est-ce que vous
avez déjà testé l'aire de street workout
est-ce que vous pratiquez un sport à
Élancourt alors moi je fais du sport
effectivement je fais beaucoup de marche
à pied j'ai pas encore eu l'occasion je
vais l'avoir parce que lorsque la
nouvelle ère dans le quartier des petits
pressers à livrer je me suis dit après
effectivement dans une tenue adaptée
avec les jeunes parce que ce qui est
intéressant dans ces deux projets ce
sont des jeunes des quartiers qui nous
ont demandé ces projets qui les ont bâti
donc ça a été co-construit avec la
population du quartier et qui nous ont
dit voilà et qu'on conçu eux-mêmes
c'est-à-dire que c'est pas nous qui
avons dit ma valeur va mettre tel était
à la Grèce qui sont venus avec un plan
voilà comment on voit les choses voilà
comment on veut faire et l'idée c'était
dire attention c'est pas une aire que
pour les jeunes c'est une aire
intergénérationnel il faut que tout le
monde puisse venir s'exprimer peuvent
faire du sport les femmes comme les
hommes autour du plateau vous avez déjà
utilisé des structures sportives à
l'extérieur ça vous arrivez ou pas avec
mes enfants
dans nos villes il y a justement cette
possibilité qui nous a offert donc ouais
bien sûr c'est vrai qu'on pense qu'on
fait souvent des parcours de santé en
forêt moi je pense à ça oui j'ai
l'impression qu'il y en a de plus en
plus dans les villes
ça se développe et nous avons proposé
l'année dernière un budget participatif
et dans le cadre de ce budget
participatif on a des rencontres toi qui
a proposé un parcours santé et nous
étions encore cet après-midi avec lui en
train de voir l'endroit comment le on
l'organise comment ils voient les choses
et c'est ça qui est intéressant et bien
merci beaucoup Thierry Michel d'avoir
répondu à nos questions je le rappelle
vous êtes le premier adjoint au maire
pour la commune d'Élancourt vous restez
avec nous on va parler d'humour à
présent